reject hello everyone thanks for coming
to our talk we're going to talk about
today and experience experimental
performance experience one that involves
not only the perform on stage but also
you as an actively participating ad hoc
performers as well so a little bit about
us first I'm Jocelyn I'm a classical
pianist and composer and here is my
collaborator I'm drew drew peterson i'm
a software engineer javascript engineer
at spotify all right so I was really
excited about Mouse's talk because music
is really a empathic activity between
the audience and the performer and today
we're going to do this extend this by
making your mobile phones into makeshift
instruments all right so a little bit
about the background i'm running a
year-long project called synesthesia
playground a project that is
interdisciplinary and collaborative
involving myself for other composers a
visual artist and drew here I'll star
software developer this project is
commissioning five multimedia works for
piano which I'll take on to the next
year the goal of this project is to make
the classical music experience
accessible dare I say transform the
classical music experience even to
something that is interactive fun
relatable and appealing to all audiences
with mobile phones and that's everybody
basically so what is this word here this
long word synesthesia our five senses
though we think of them as separate
turns out not to be so distinct when we
hear sounds we often think of space like
high-end no sounds we think of colors
like bright Oh dull or temperature like
warm and I see so some people feel this
intermixing of the senses more acutely
than others and this neurological
phenomenon is called synesthesia so for
instance synesthetes people with
synesthesia might see sounds very
vividly see colors associated with
specific harmonies or pictures and so on
or have some kind of tactile experience
when they see colors on here sounds so
synesthesia inspires an altogether new
way of listening to music through all
the senses of our bodies so the goal of
synesthesia playground is to get at this
bodily experience appealing to sound
through other senses now throughout
Western historical thought music has
been debated as a pure abstract
idealized form of art however you cannot
only listen to music in your mind the
split between mind and body is just an
artificial divide that takes away from
the fullness of this bodily visceral
experience in fact the 20th century a
phenomenologist maurice merleau-ponty
here goes even a step further and
associate every knowledge that we have
every experience we have in this world
is first and foremost through our body
no thought no emotion if ever away from
the bodily knowledge that you have
acquired throughout years of living so
synesthesia playground aims to celebrate
this bodily experience bringing music
music from the abstract and the head
to this very basic full human experience
alright so that's the context of
synesthesia playground this year-long
project the piece we're discussing today
is one of the five commissioned works
while the other works deal with the
bodily experience of an individual this
piece we're talking about today involves
the collective experience of
interconnected communal bodies now music
has always been something that humans
have done collectively as a form of
cultural sharing its practiced as a type
of communal bonding since the beginnings
of the ages whether it be in ceremonies
in churches and late night jam sessions
and so on for this piece our vision is
this type of communal music making we
want to create a collective structured
improvisation involving a flexible
amount of people with one guiding
improviser me at the front we aim to
transform the classical piano concert
into a collaborative bonding musical
experience with instruments relevant to
the 21st century our mobile phones so we
decided to use mobile gestural
technologies both in terms of screen and
a seller ometer detected gestures
because it appeals immediately to the
bodily sense of touch and off movement
now what could a particular gesture
sound like like a shake or a flash or a
slow scratch what could a certain touch
like tickling or tapping sounds like now
in addition the Kinect is going to be
used to detect the pianists movements
they cannot augment the piano by so
using gestures in the air with sounds so
for instance one of the gestures I use
is this very dramatic arm gesture and
its associated with a drastic change in
the pace of the music
alright so I'm the pianist at the front
and the audience somehow interacts with
me and you know amongst themselves as
well so now we've got a framework let's
talk a little bit about the content of
the piece visit the set up we have here
actually opens up a lot of opportunities
as well as questions now what is the
relationship between the pianist and the
audience what's the relationship between
the audience members from one to the
other more practical question is how do
I juggle interactivity with kind of
performative satisfaction or
performative sportsmanship now more
philosophically is the issue of game
versus performance so game is about you
know involvement where everyone's
participating doing stuff and
performance involves kind of
spectatorship so is it still a
performance if everyone is a player and
there are no spectators or are the game
players also spectating so on this
spectrum how much of the piece is
actually a performance and how much of
it is a game so with this new kind of
performance / game consists of in place
I've decided to exploit this very
interactive environment by coming up
with a piece about social dynamics
psychology and social behavior so think
of a room of people at a party like Ren
was boat party how do people relate to
each other how do people act in response
to what they hear do you chime in when
people talk or do you fill in silences
when people don't talk in some
situations people choose to talk over
one another well some people just you
know choose to reflect back or imitate
what they hear now self-consciousness is
something we are all familiar with at a
party what do people do in response to
how con
sures of of themselves and in the
presence of an influential individual is
the possibility of just mindless echoing
or emulation so the piece that I've
wrote I've written heightens this bodily
experience of these social interactions
how does it feel to be hesitant and
uncertain anxious self-conscious elf
conscious or confident so I've turned
these kind of social behaviors and
consciousness into sound into a piece of
music alright so back to the concert
hall now we have a room full of people
each with their phones so I've split up
the audience into four quadrants now for
each quadrant or group green red blue
and yellow I devised game like rules for
gesturing with the phones these rules
explore how people act and listen to
each other in different social dynamics
so here is an example of one of them so
in this one the audience is asked to be
hyper aware of their own bodies like be
very aware of swallowing your saliva so
which is which is a bodily experience of
being self-conscious being hyper aware
of what you're doing which usually is
automatic so these rules change as the
piece is played as the soundscape
changes the audience is also given
different rules to adapt to the
environment all right and I'm talking so
let's hear some excerpts of the preview
performance we had last week at spectrum
NYC an experimental music venue alright
so the piece
is divided into three sections so this
is the first section which you're
hearing now so this section is called
metals you can hear a lot of metallic
down inside the piano stuff you can see
very dark but some some of the people
are raising their phones to admit sound
from the mobile phones
the rules of the mobile phones that you
said they have all right so all right so
this is section 2 that was the Kinect
gesture to go into section 2 section 2
is called underwater and the audience is
compelled to be self-conscious or hyper
work themselves following the rules on
their phones all right so this is
another example so this is the gesture
going from
the underwater section 2 section 3
alright so that's the content and the
kind of lots of it behind the piece but
how did we do it yes so let's find out
the answer in case you're wondering is
just a lot of JavaScript just JavaScript
all over the place here's the setup you
saw a little exercise before I'm going
to be moving pretty quickly because
there's a live demo so forgive me if I'm
speeding but this is actually my brother
and joseline at the piano up at the top
in the middle there's a little like I
looking thing like Curiosity rover at
that's the Kinect looking at Jocelyn and
my brothers on the computer controlling
the Kinect so there were a few
challenges with this thing and it's a
challenge to get any sort of phones to
kind of coordinate this you know this
many phones we had about 30 people which
was a great turnout we're going to have
even more today so hopefully it works
we'll see what happens but I started
writing my own thing and then turns out
Oh someone already wrote a thing that
does this exactly it's a server called
rhizome and you should all check it out
it's amazing it's basically just an
automatic messaging service with
supports for web sockets and osc which
is a sound protocol it does things like
reconnect automatically and also just
does some pub/sub stuff so here's how
like a typical real-time server app
might work you've got the client like a
phone and some server and the client
says like hey what's going on the server
is like there's what's going on sends it
back and then also just like sending
back updates to the client because the
server knows everything about the state
and in this case the server would know
everything about the performance and
that kind of looks like this
topologically in the what we did for
this performance is used instead a
distributed messaging server app which
of course still has a centralized server
still has the rhizome central server but
certain clients are elevated to a super
client status and that's actually where
all of the state and logic of the app
are so a client might tell the server
hey tell me about world events the
server says sure I'll do that when they
come in and then a super client such as
the computer that I was controlling
during the performance which has all the
state and logic and is may be receiving
events from the connect
sends a message to the central server
saying hey everyone there's a new world
event and then the server distributes it
to everyone what this means is that the
central server is really just routing
messages and and doesn't have any logic
built into it and it looks kind of like
this in our performance we had a few
different super clients the conductor
and the performer and we also had other
special clients like the laptop
controlling the Kinect so the Kinect
would send a signal to the central
server which routes it to the conductor
because it knows the conductor is said I
want to know about connect events the
conductor goes hey cool this is like
this is like a world event thing I
should do so it sends out a new event
and it gets sent out to all the clients
so just very fairly standard pub/sub and
this is not like a crazy architecture
but it took me a while to figure out and
that's why I'm sharing it with you
because I'm like oh that's how you do
this it's nothing it's something that
crazy and you might be thinking like hey
the conductor always output state to the
client in one direction and you know one
direction state and you just like you
have to mention react well the second
you talk about one direction in state
and i just want to mention it because i
did use it for the views and you're all
going to see it in a little bit it
worked really well to go from the state
coming in to each audience client state
lessly render and then each client is
basically just a terminal that doesn't
know anything but its own potential it
knows what it can render it doesn't know
when it needs to render or how just that
it can also use these tools and I'm just
going to keep going because you know i'm
sure you all have used these before next
challenge just physical challenge was
networking AKA how many clients can
connect to my Airport Express I'm sorry
extreme this guy right down here the
answer is 50 you can search high and
wide the internet and you will come up
with 50 it's hard coded so if you want
more you need to do your own Wi-Fi setup
and the author of the rhizome server has
actually written a blog post about how
to do this and it basically involves
custom ApS separate router separate
switch and hooking it all up and
carrying it all for the venue short
answer for us we were expecting no more
than 50 luckily so the airport extreme
yeah brought it home the next challenge
we faced was something I'm calling
audience engineering you might consider
it user experience or user engineering
or something this is this was a complex
piece to get people to buy into for
example they had to connect to a
specific Wi-Fi access point type in a
password visit a web page all on their
phone and check that audio works and
check that they have accelerometers
working all these things so how do we do
this well one thing we did was we just
printed out physical cards that had the
Wi-Fi information on them and it was
still troublesome for people people
still had trouble but it worked out
better the passwords there because you
know you have to have a password when in
New York because otherwise people will
try to steal your free internet and even
though it wasn't connected to the
Internet it would have taken up one of
those 50 slots and last but not least
people well it's really hard to type an
IP address on a phone let alone on a
desktop let alone the phone so I had
them type in playground CO and I did
that by using my own DNS server not my
own i didn't write it I just started it
up it's super simple I had every single
thing any query that people asked going
to pointing at my server so even google
com would have pointed at my server all
their mail and stuff would have gone to
my server so check this out if you're
ever doing some kind of like custom art
piece within an installation you want
people to connect to it it's way easier
than typing in an IP address next
challenge the connects the connect to
how many of you have used to connect how
many of you have programmed for a
connect Wow awesome so you know that you
know it's really cool super powerful but
for me this boil down to do I really
have to use windows because I'm a Mac
I'm primarily on a Mac and I knew that
carrying laptops around we pretty
difficult and the windows windows is
like you know do you want to program
your own body appendage and figure
tracking and I said yeah that sounds
like a ton of fun do you want to do that
you know what others have spent a PhD
program doing in two weeks and I said
okay fine Windows you win I'll use I'll
use you and in this case it was actually
my brother who did the mostly connect
this is him testing out front and back
detection you can see it knows which
hand is which even though he spins this
is his contact information there if
you're curious
and this is the connect you can see it
it tracking Jocelyn I just want to show
it to you it's way at the bottom there
but it's kind of cool so you'll see her
do the gesture
and it's actually very accurate
and that triggered the section the next
part of the piece of the audio okay by
the way shaking your phone doing
gestures you'd think these are solved
they're not they're totally not they're
really hard there's all these techniques
for doing it I studied a few of them I
didn't have a time to look into all them
but I wanted to walk through at least
one which is called dynamic time warping
just want to mention it really because I
want to make sure we have time for more
stuff but basically you take a sliding
window of events you take a pattern and
then you try to match the events to your
pattern and it tries to compensate for
the patterns not perfectly matching
which is cool this is a cool paper you
can read about it explains it pretty
well however I did it totally wrong and
it just ended up working by lucky my
lucky chance really so there was that
and in addition one other technique for
gestures that I used was just like
taking the magnitude of the vector of
the events as they're coming in and
saying if they are all greater than 1.8
then do it it's a magic number it's just
totally magical and it kind of works but
I would love it to be better
unfortunately slow time and finally won
one thing that was a challenge with the
gestures was reality versus the intent
of the piece the intent of the composer
and the intent of the the you know the
the idea of the music some of these
gestures were really hard to do so
instead of doing them we just changed
the gesture which was a compromise that
I was willing to make maybe not joseline
as much but you know we kind of were up
against a wall with some things so now
that we are now that you've gotten
through that tech stuff just because I
thought you might be curious let's do
something or not you're never supposed
to do which is a live demo so I love it
if everyone could try this out we're
going to try a performance this thing
right here so everyone pull out your
phones has to be a phone can't be a
laptop it can be an iPad or a tablet
visit this IP address and hopefully
hopefully this works and the Wi-Fi holds
make sure you're on the
the cat pictures here Wi-Fi if you get a
begin button go ahead and tap it I'm
going to escape out of this for a moment
just so I can make sure that things are
fluxing over here yeah we've got people
connecting so that's good okay that's
great here's the IP address again there
we go and when we've got like a
significant amount of people who are
pressing that button and hearing square
waves I want to hear your square waves
come on hopefully it were there's one
yes by the way I am asking you to turn
on your phone volume so it's okay if it
rings it's okay if it blew you know it's
going to and that's totally fine it's
very slow i'm sure so much javascript is
it coming is it like pausing for some
people like your nice nice it's kind of
their sort of okay let's wait like two
minutes and see if we can get everyone
kind of connected also it shows the grid
there and the grid is somewhat arbitrary
but it's basically you know the front is
us so the top of your phone is us yeah
is anyone having like just crazy crazy
issues I feel like we're kind of good
here oh really it won't stop playing
okay oh no well I do love the sound of
square waves frankly especially in the
morning or the afternoon where are we
all right Berlin alright cool
feel like maybe we're yeah we're okay
yeah so obviously this the demo is going
to not have a piano Stan we didn't
sponsor my talk so there's going to be
kind of like a modified demo where I'm
not going to be really that much
involved so you guys are kind of like an
autonomous system just doing your own
improvising for most of the time but
let's just see something here question
Oh question wizard oh no no the the
Wi-Fi of the convention cat pictures
here cat pictures here get your cat
pictures actually miles had great ones
we had none yeah failing you all all
right I think my socket did die hoo boy
wow it died alright well we'll just try
it again this is how you test scale by
the way in production it's actually this
I want to talk about this but it's a
very difficult thing to test to get this
many phones give it a minute get a
minute I should hit the wrong the other
button alright see ya
ok
there we go cool we have 64 people
connected or so maybe some more cool all
right you just try it yeah all right
let's just try it we're running out of
time I don't want to go over too much
here so uh what oh no I'm still getting
requests sort of yeah they're coming in
hmm I mean my we'll see what might have
my laptop can handle it but all right
let's just do later let's try it go
ahead oh oh did I again no did the Wi-Fi
actually die
oh no did it did it really die I think
it really died because if my phone
doesn't have Wi-Fi anymore all right
we'll do it from the will do it from the
computer here all right all right here
we go so yeah this is hang on a sec hang
I said no it's not it doesn't work that
right there we go try that did it quick
oh [ __ ] does it not it's a touch you I
it doesn't have click events it has tap
events hang on a sec there's a way to do
this this is i use firefox every day
just so you know just not we're in
responsive mode device there we go thank
you could be a six yes you ready yep
just okay alright hopefully it follows
along hopefully your phones are sink
Oh
so all right
Oh
I have you gotta go almost ok so I think
we're like totally out of time sorry for
going over I hope it was okay you want
to see anything else yeah uh well uh so
everyone's a rock star now so yeah
reject